EVO got its start in the arcades of Southern California, but has since grown to the biggest fighting game
tournament in the world.
Over its first thirteen years, it went from just a handful of competitors, to over a thousand.
And it's crowned champions, like Alex Valle.
Justin Wong.
And Daigo Umehara
The tournament survived the dark ages of the mid 2000s,
And exploded in 2009 when Street Fighter IV came out.
But people couldn't even imagine, just how big it was going to get.
EVO began as a way for the American FGC to come together and settle the score,
But eventually,
it became an international festival, dedicated to celebrating the FGC, preserving Arcade culture
and crowning world champions.
And after surviving a dark age and weathering the storm of the mid-2000s, Evo bounced back
in 2009.
Thanks in part to Street Fighter IV’s arrival.
(Casting)
After winning in 2009, Street Fighter legend Daigo Umehara turned his historic legacy into
something more modern, more real.
And in 2010, he did it all over again.
The Super Street Fighter IV tournament at Evo 2010 saw nearly double the entrants, but
all the warriors in the world couldn’t stop Daigo, who brought down Shizza, Mike Ross
and beat Ricki Ortiz twice to take home his second straight Evo win.
"Daigo Umehara is your Evolution 2010 Champion."
"Wow."
"He still reigns supreme."
Meanwhile, the Marvel 2 show was just about over.
By the time Justin won in 2010, it seemed like it was done as a tournament game.
Street Fighter IV brought Evo back to life, but fans simply couldn’t believe that Capcom
could do it again.
That is, not until Marvel vs. Capcom 3.
Just like with Street Fighter IV, Capcom did what many thought was impossible, and gave
fans a follow up to a legendary, decade-old game.It was an era just before Marvel’s
movies got huge, an era before the FGC was being integrated into the larger esports ecosystem.
It was basically the only time it could happen.
(Casting)
Viscant took first in 2011, surprising plenty of people who expected one of the old Marvel
gods to take the tournament, But Justin tailed behind in third place.
"Justin Wong. He's smiling, I know he's gonna take this one inside."
"He worked really hard."
In 2012 Justin dropped to a tie for 7th.
as Fchamp took the top spot.
"Champ 2012 Evolution Champion, wow."
The next year though, Justin got close.
He was in the Grand Finals against Flocker, and played an unbelievably close set.
"You know what Flocker won, but I definitely give the MVP to Justin Wong."
"He had to climb."
And finally, in 2014, Justin reclaimed his throne, with an underdog win against Chris G
"Justin Wong takes it!"
"He takes it!"
Justin’s win, and of course, his now iconic
pop-off, all-but ended an era of Marvel at Evo.
Sure, the game continued to appear at the tournament for three more years, but things
felt like they were slowing down.
If only a little.
KaneBlueRiver took an underdog victory in 2015
"Keep in mind, this is the first tournament that KBR has ever won."
"What a tournament for it to be."
ChrisG won in 2016 before a frightening visit from the spirit of Marvel,
"Chris G"
And in 2017, RyanLV, the hometown hero, won what looks to be the last official Marvel
vs Capcom 3 tournament Evo will ever see.
(Casting)
While Marvel 3’s history at Evo was explosive, the franchise left the event
with more of a whimper.
Marvel vs. Capcom Infinite was left off the official roster in 2018, due to weak sales
and Evo not believing there were enough players to hold a tournament.
And while Marvel will be at the event as a side tournament, the biggest fighting game
tournament in the world looks like it’s leaving one of the games that built it behind.
But in Marvel’s glory days at Evo, it created some of the tournament’s hypest moments.
In 2011, Justin Wong updated his legendary 2007 comeback with a new one in Marvel 3.
(Casting)
And eight-year-old Noah Solis shocked the world with his own incredible Marvel play.
"Great job to Noah, came out here."
"I mean how do you not give that kid all the respect in the world."
"Top 48 out of like 1500 people for an eight year old kid."
In Street Fighter that year, Saudi Arabian player Latif went deeper in Street Fighter
IV than anyone could have expected.
Latif has eliminated Daigo 'The Beast' Umehara."
The next year, 2012 belonged to international competitors, as Infiltration won Street Fighter IV.
(Casting)
And Korea’s MadKoF dueled Mexico’s Bala for the King of Fighters XIII title.
2013 brought controversy, but it also brought back a game that would change Evo forever.
Evo’s organizers announced the seven tournament games for 2013 in January, but also announced
a charity drive to add an eighth game to the lineup.
The rules were simple.
Whichever community raised the most money for breast cancer research got their game at Evo.
There were over a dozen games vying for the last slot at Evo, but the real competition
was between indie darling Skullgirls and Melee, which hadn’t been at Evo since 2007.
(Casting)
Both games broke five digit donations, but by February, Melee came out on top, raising
$94,683 for breast cancer research out
of the total $225,744 raised by the FGC at large.
Skullgirls has never been an official Evo game.
Melee, on the other hand, would go on to flourish at Evo.
But not before some hiccups.
The day before Evo 2013, Nintendo barred the tournament organizers from not only streaming
the Melee tournament, but holding it.
"Nintendo has taken it away from the fans. Literally saying that, Evo can hold the tournament, but you can't
actually host the games. This is freaking ridiculous you can't even. They can't stream now."
"It's their IP, they can do what they want. And they didn't present us with any options to keep it open
they were just, "Hey we want to shut you down."
Nintendo doubled back on their decision later that day.
Evo didn’t even do anything, it was the power of the fans who clamored for their game
to be on fighting games’ most important, most prestigious stage.
"We wanted to be recognized as a fighting game, first of all. And we also wanted to be recognized as an esport
So it was really really important for us to get into Evo so that we can have that recognition."
The next year, Smash was at Evo, and Nintendo sponsored the tournament.
"I wanted to officially wish you luck in the final stages of the Super Smash Bros. Melee tournament at EVO 2014."
Smash has gone on to become one of Evo’s biggest games, with both Melee and Super Smash
Bros. for Wii U right behind Street Fighter as the event’s largest tournaments.
Year after year.
Melee went from 692 players in 2013 to 970 the next year, then 1,873 in 2015, and 2,373
in 2016.
Smash 4, which joined Evo in 2015, debuted with 1,929 players.
The next year, it was at 2,656.
In fact Evo 2015 and 2016 are the four biggest Smash tournaments of all time .
Smash cemented its place at Evo with growing attendance numbers year over year, but things
haven’t been easy.
Tensions between the fighting game and Smash communities have led to plenty of disagreements
between the two scenes.
The most notable example?
Smash’s struggle for the Sunday stage.
"I think Melee really really needs to, you know calm down with that and they really need to just
accept what's given to us, like don't ask for more. We're already at Evo, don't be like spoiled.
I think the Smash community is like really spoiled."
Melee and Smash 4 traded their spots in Sunday’s stage show back and forth, with the 2017 Smash
4 Top 8 even being televised on Disney XD.
"The 2017 EVO World Championship Super Smash Bros. Live event Sunday 6 eastern 3 pacific on DXP."
Meanwhile, certain fighting game fans often wondered why Smash got to have two spots at
Evo, while series like , say, Street Fighter, only got one.
But at this point, there’s no getting Smash out of Evo, and likely, no getting Evo out of Smash.
(Casting)
Evo’s spotlight shines bright, and like it brought Smash to new relevance outside of
just the Smash community, plenty of games have made legends at Evo.
KoF had yet another incredible Grand Finals in 2013, when Reynald and Woo battled for the fate of the game.
(Casting)
"It was like so hype and energetic, I remember Reynald putting on the USA shades.
You know you have the shades with the American flag on there after winning
he was waving the American flag and everything like that. That was also probably one of the greatest
Evo Top 8 moments as well."
While Xian and Tokido’s SFIV grand finals set was somewhat overshadowed by Infiltration’s
Hakan pick in the Losers’ semis.
2014 brought Axe’s now-iconic 4-stock on Silent Wolf,
"Destructiooooooon!
an unbelievable run from Blazblue player Galileo,
(Casting)
and the biggest win the EU FGC had ever seen.
"To be honest with you I think what he accomplished is probably one of the greatest accomplishments
of fighting games.
You know, history. To be able to go through the losers bracket and take out so many killers.
And end up winning Evo against a guy like Bonchan. You know who at the time felt like he was
the shoe-in to win Evo that year. For me it was a really important moment.
And really kind of opened the door a lot of- for the world wide scene of Street Fighter."
Evo has changed over the years though.
It’s not just the games that are played or the size of the venue, it’s the atmosphere.
While Evo got its start as a way to preserve arcade culture, it eventually became the source
of a new one.
Tournament culture.
Evo was the first massive fighting game tournament, and while we have plenty of majors all over
the world now, Evo was first.
And that means something.
"The community around fighting games are amazing like, so close knit and very humble and very like
supportive of each other, it's a really great experience."
Almost everyone at Evo is there to play, and even when they’re out, they’re playing
casual matches, meeting up with old friends and celebrating their love of fighting games together.
Evo is a mecca for fighting game culture.
Nearly every fighting game fan in the world wants to go, at least once, to know what it’s like
to be in that room.
To watch that stage, to get to play with the best, the worst and everyone else.
Evo is a celebration of the fighting game community, but it takes an incredible group
of people to make that celebration worth it, year after year.
2015 might be best known for the viral “What are you standing up for” clip.
"What are you standing up for?"
"Why?"
"Oh my god!"
"Woshige thought it was over. And stood up, and Ogawa gave him no remorse."
"That is exactly what happens. Do not celebrate pop off!"
"Oh my god!"
But the play in other tournaments that year was just as good.
ZeRo won Evo’s first Smash 4 tournament without dropping a single game.
(Casting)
And in the Street Fighter IV grand finals, the unthinkable happened.
"No. No. No James, not like this. Not like this."
Momochi’s stick may have broken mid-set, but he soldiered through and won the tournament.
(Casting)
Perhaps the most notable shift from the underground Evos of yesteryear to the glitz and glamor
of the Mandalay Bay stage broadcast on ESPN is the amount of developer support the tournament
has seen in recent years.
Capcom first kicked money into the Evo Street Fighter prize pool in 2006, but their contribution
has grown over the years.
These days their contributions include more money, status as the biggest tournament on
the Capcom Pro Tour and even new character announcements.
Ultra Street Fighter IV was even announced at Evo 2013, with a trailer packed with Evo footage.
But Capcom isn’t the only company to turn around and support Evo and the FGC at large
thanks to the tournament’s incredible growth.
Nintendo went from blocking Smash tournaments in 2013 to sponsoring Evo every year since.
Namco Bandai announced Tekken 7 at Evo 2014, and have been announcing new characters at
Evo ever since, blowing fans away with their Geese Howard announcement in 2017.
And Arc System Works has become one of Evo’s biggest supporters, announcing new Guilty
Gear and Dragon Ball FighterZ characters, along with BlazBlue Cross Tag Battle at Evo 2017.
"Yes!"
And at launch, Cross Tag Battle was even branded with the Evo logo on the shrink wrap, telling
potential buyers that it  was an Evo game.
But there is some push back. Cross Tag Battle, was added to EVO 2018's lineup months before the game
was launched.
Leading to some controversy.
But, either through luck or intuition.
Evo got it right, and Cross Tag Battle was popular.
Or maybe its presence at Evo made people take an interest in the game.
Evo was built from the ground up by fighting game fans, in a time when support like this
was unheard of.
Now, companies are flocking to Evo because it’s the best way to reach the FGC, the
core audience they seemed to abandon for years.
"You may call me, G."
And at this point, it’s possible that these companies need Evo more than Evo needs them.
In 2016, Evo exploded again.
The launch of Street Fighter V earlier that year brought fans to Evo in droves, with more
than 5,000 people in one bracket.
No other fighting game tournament has even come close since, not even the next Evo.
2017 was smaller than 2016, but only because the SFV explosion was unprecedented.
It was bigger than 2009, bigger than anything.
And that growth has also led to other fighting games finding success at Evo.
(Casting)
Tekken joined the 1,000 club in 2017 and even smaller games, like Guilty Gear and Killer
Instinct have seen strong turnouts at Evo.
(Casting)
Evo itself has even grown to include Evo Japan, a 2018 tournament that marked Evo’s first
time outside North America.
Evo 2016 was bigger than ever, which meant the moments were even more explosive.
Hungrybox shocked the world with an incredible reset and victory over Melee defending champion, Armada.
(Casting)
And LI Joe fought for America in Street Fighter V, all the way to Top 8.
And while Evo 2017 may have had smaller attendance numbers, the tournament still saw some incredible runs.
JDCR and Saint duked it out for Tekken 7’s first place trophy.
(Casting)
Salem emerged triumphant over ZeRo after a grueling, 10-game Smash 4 Grand Finals.
And Tokido made one of the greatest Top 8 runs of all time at Evo, ending it with a
message of love for the FGC.
"Just one thing I want to say. Fighting game is, something so great."
The next year, Tokido made it back to grand finals, but Street Fighter crowned an unexpexted champion.
"Problem-X has taken Evolution 2018. And all of UK is elated. They have run up there to swarm him,
Tokido, has been sent home in second place."
And just before that, the Dragonball FighterZ Grand Finals between Sonic Fox and Go1,
was the most viewed set in EVO history.
(Casting)
There is nothing in the world, quite like Evo.
No esports tournament in the world has the history, the legacy.
No tournament has the sheer number of competitors, all of whom get that same shot at the top.
No tournament brings the hype, the joy, the sadness and the incredible feeling of victory
that comes with emerging from hundreds, from thousands of competitors as the champion.
But there’s more to Evo than just the winner.
Evo was built by the FGC, and each year is made not just by just the people behind the
scenes, working their asses off.
It’s made by every competitor, every spectator, every stream monster who contributes to the experience.
Evo is about the FGC.
It’s a celebration of a community that’s been through everything.
It’s the greatest tournament in the gaming world,
"And that is the best way to put it, Evo is love, the people come back this event is unlike anything else.
In the entire video game world."
and no matter what happens, it only
gets better every year.
"Hadouken!"
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.